okay for people who are joining this
live stream
this is a meeting about language
completeness and consistency
and we have a variety of topics here so
first one
is dollar timed out which has been used
in various places
right well that's the very interesting
thing about it that
when we did our survey we actually
didn't come up with very many
places that actually use it um
and we briefly started talking about
this last time right so
uh so low level evaluation related
functions return dollar aborted
um so dollar time let me actually start
at the beginning
dollar time that was documented in
version seven
um and
um but i think the only
function that we have found that
actually
returns it is uh
ping time um
and may it's used internally in a couple
of places like people decide
internally to pass around but things
like
you know a url download or
whatnot if they time out they
return a failure object and so
the difference between aborted and timed
out is
aborted was actively stopped right
i mean timed out in a sense was actively
stopped too
although it more refers to some external
thing
you know time constraint is like we were
running it just didn't work
whereas timed out is more like something
out in the world was supposed to happen
it didn't happen
right right so
in the ping time example like we paint
you know we sent the pings we waited we
waited we never got a response so we
just gave up after whatever period of
time
um whereas time constraint it says you
know once one second has done you will
stop whatever you're doing and propagate
in the
dollar aborted to the outside world
because
i've told you you can only spend one
second even trying to do what i'm asking
you to do all right so look url download
would be a candidate for
timed out it just doesn't happen to use
it whereas find equational proof is
absolutely not a candidate for timed out
you know it's timed out is it wasn't our
fault
right whereas aborted is it was
something happening internal to our
system
and we've chosen to kill it
okay so say that last sentence again i
feel like well
probably because i'm eating a piece of
chocolate okay but but i mean the the um
uh i'm saying timed out is something
was supposed to happen in the outside
world and didn't happen not our fault
right aborted is it was something
happening within our ecosystem
and we something chose to abort it
right that you're right and that
something could be a user pressing
uh abort or could be that you you know
the user chose to use time constrained
or internally we
you know uh yeah i mean i'm not thrilled
that the behavior
when you press abort interactively
and when there's an internal time
constraint is the same i'm not thrilled
about that i think it'd be better if it
was different
but okay so what's the question here
um right well the the
this um
[Music]
right the the the question is what do we
want to do
with this symbol right do we want to do
we want
to phase it out and return and instead
use failure objects or do we want to
so look i mean again
okay what this question about time out
boy i mean there's a there's a whole
class of network timeouts
basically and then the question is if
it's in the cloud
when it's sort of all on us does it
count as an external timeout or not
i i'm beginning to think it might be
better to phase it out
i have the impression that dollar
timeout is like a
sibling of dollar failed and in the same
way that now we can use dollar fame or
failure
i think this could be some sort of
possibility offered to users and
they can use total timeout or failure
for expressivity
yeah maybe okay i don't think this is a
breast pressing issue at least no
it was it was a question that was posed
at some point and
you know we we had an answer so we
brought it back okay
fine which in the answer is it isn't
used very much
right okay all right let's keep going
here
okay so this uh is probably
just a bug i think or a couple of bugs
but they're
uh there's uh
right so there's an expression with uh
you know two associations in it
and if you use associate
2 then it sort of works
but it doesn't return just the
expression that was modified
right it returns all of expression
that's just wrong
isn't it i mean yeah it's certainly
right
what it's just wrong i mean any
expression that has
a you know l value
you know is operated on with an r
value it should return the r value
um well it's
because no it doesn't return the r value
it returns
the the par the l value that was
actually modified
right if you do part right uh of
well fair enough it's like saying i plus
equals two it returns the
returns you know three or whatever right
and yes and if you do par if you do
you know x par part
two plus equals two it'll return
whatever is the result of a plot adding
two
just to that part and this is right so
the second
the append two is correct because it's
showing you the result of applying
b just to the second association
where it's to associate two singles just
a bug
right right
right and then the second issue is that
[Music]
um
right it it's not evaluating the the
l value parts at all so you
you know you you have to inject right so
when i did the
uh you know when i put in a little
little wrong
bug again okay um
yeah the let the the associate ii
was uh let's just say the associate to
rough page is pretty sparse so i
you know just wanted to bring this up
raising another question
ethan is raising on our live stream
efficiency of append to
now clearly in modern times with the
queue data structure and so on
linked list data structures we could
make it efficient
um right i mean another way i thought
i don't know that the pen two will act
directly on a data structure
right no it doesn't but i mean what i'm
saying is what i'm saying is that that
we could you know in principle with some
weak hashing
method or something we could behind the
scenes
be doing that i mean we've talked about
this for years and it was one of the
objectives of the compiler
project to be able to do this and you
know
in some time in the future when we have
just in time compilation for things like
this
that might happen automatically but i
think it's worth the question
to the compiler team whether there is
some way
using weak hashing or some such other
thing if you've seen an append to happen
many times
on the same expression right maybe you
should maintain something
and and the results not be looked at
maybe you should maintain something
that allows you to uh you know to do
those
those updates efficiently do you see
what i'm saying
uh in the context of function compiler
i'm no in the context of the system in
general i mean just like
we have a bunch of cached data
structures
that help us do certain operations
faster usually using weak hashing
methods
this will be another one of those
uh yeah your statement is that
if the system sees append to
c comma element happen over and over and
over again
but no reads of c other than inside the
append to
then c should be temporarily replaced
with an internal bag
until such time as um
yeah or or in fact c would just become
something which is you know colon equals
to a bag on packer
right it would actually be colon equals
c equals bag unpacker
yeah so as soon as the thing is unpacked
you know it's
it's gone but yes that would be the idea
let's let's raise that question i mean
this is more of a
mark et cetera question uh well i i
agree with that statement but
i will just add the observation of i
mean that that involves
changing the evaluator right that's not
oh it doesn't
no it doesn't it involves changing
append to
no because because your statement was
noticing that c is never read and is
only append to it
i i think there's a way to do this let's
not solve that engineering problem in
this meeting
nothing okay i'm skeptical
i but all right and and right and and
and there's also prepend
too and and how what what if it's
interleaved depends twos and pre-pens
twos but nothing else you know what i
bet there's a way to do it you want me
to invest
i'm not i'm
i agree but i think i think there will
be a way to do it that users for example
i don't know noticing reference counts
the last time it came through that type
of thing
okay having some table somewhere that
i don't know i mean i don't know how to
do it but i you know i didn't
i'm not inventing the engineering
solution right now but i think it's been
a persistent problem
that has been something which for a
decade we've said we're going to fix
this with compilation so now we have a
certain level of compilation we could
fix it
so let's if if nothing else
i see what you're okay i think i i i
i didn't understand what you were
suggesting at first so you're you're
suggesting that we
create you know because of the
compilation we can create a data
structure
that append two can refer to
to speed things up yes basically
yes but it would be invisible to the
user right
yes i i understand okay i i understand
the suggestion now and
i agree and i you know i think we're
working on things like this for
you know for like numerical evaluation
um
but uh yes that that this is definitely
a question for mark and rob
and tommy right now you don't
you just use create data structure of
cue the right data structure i don't
even know
uh well depends on whether you just want
to append or uh
yeah right so or do both uh
right if you want to prepend and
you you need a linked list
and of course the other way to do this
is with uh
reap and so right reap and so are the
sort of the pre-compiled way to do it
uh right
i mean if we do this let's see um
what are we saying append i mean this is
you know this is my not very favorite
design here of how this works right
just doing this right if i just do that
that looks correct to me
okay there we go so
why oh i see
okay brilliant all right so now let's do
the test
that ethan is proposing we do here
oops what am i doing here i wanted that
in the do
thank you syntax coloring
it's respectable now let's watch it be
not very respectable
let's say cc equals null list
this is going to be absolutely horrible
i'm not going to even use 10 to the
sixth i'm going to use 10 to the 5.
grind grind grind grind grind
but you see this is what we could do if
if we had a
you know an uh you know
a hidden connection to cc to this
queue it will work beautifully obviously
for the user
you know if they already know what's
going on okay so that's totally horrible
that's like 200 times slower so
you know horrible but um
anyway let's let's raise this if nothing
else can we make sure it's in the next
compiler meeting please
do that okay uh
ethan is commenting that there are
timeouts related to dynamic as well
options like dynamic evaluation timeout
that's interesting and i'm not sure we
understand how
our dynamic timeouts are a whole
different story which probably nobody in
this meeting particularly knows about
is that a true well i i uh you know
when i was telling john last week how
bad i am
at dynamics he said well i'm probably in
the top 100 in the world
so well
look it is an interesting question
whether we should review sometime
i mean the whole mechanism that you know
of dynamics and the way that dynamic
tickling works
and all this kind of thing i don't think
we've looked at that for years
and you know i think it's pretty clever
but you know i kind of wonder whether
with modern
methods and modern you know like for
example the refresh times
and um you know the whole callback
mechanism
when things are modified
is that obviously right or could we you
know
the the shocking thing everybody says
about everything is you know use machine
learning to figure it out better
although that usually doesn't seem to
work well but you know this question of
what should the optimal refresh time be
for this
particular thing there are times when
for example
i have a notebook it has lots of
dynamics in it it slows to a crawl
and the fact is i'd be happy to have my
dynamics
you know it's it's not doing the correct
scheduling
load balancing i'd be much happier to
have my dynamics be slower by not by
notebook not
slow to a crawl if that makes sense
right although that is
right a function of how people chose to
write their dynamics right they can
choose them to be preemptive or
non-preemptive
and if lots of people decide to all
be preemptive then which is the default
right
depends on how you generate the dynamic
but yes
probably more than i know i mean as in i
you know i don't i don't mess with the
with preemptive or not in dynamics ever
i'd completely forgotten about it now
that you remind me about it i remember
but
but i i don't ever mess with that
so you know if there's something there
that needs to be thought about i think
that should be exposed
right i might be a topic to discuss
okay it's uh right obviously we would
need john
for that indeed all right let's let's go
on
um so we started talking about this
next item last week uh or i guess two
weeks ago
yes yes and uh i think
i think we think we resolved it or not
we think we
agreed on on what the issue is i don't
think we agreed on what the name
of the new option is okay and i wonder
how this relates to tree mapping which
we've been
discussing today well that's a
perfect question for ian ian
i i was at the new in 12-2 webinar so i
missed the ild meeting so you might need
to bring me
well the main issue is mapping onto data
payloads or mapping onto subtrees
is one of the key issues of tree map
is he in with us here yeah i i don't
think this
issue connects with tree map but maybe
i'm
not seeing it okay so
the proposed new item
this is this is accounting for head
structure
in determining levels is that correct
correct um and
uh sort of in in
both halves of it what do you mean by
both halves you mean you mean that that
when you say minus two well this isn't
saying mine
there's which parts of the expression do
you look at and then there's the
separate question of
how do you measure the depth of a part
of an expression
right how do you measure the depth of
the expression altogether i mean heads
arrow full
will be measuring depth including the
heads exactly
right i think full is better than all
okay
um i mean i would say the description is
something like
includes heads in full or something
and and so the idea would be then if i
say
map all heads arrow full
then i am burrowing all the way into the
heads is that correct
well so this only determines what you
consider to be at a negative level
what what about deciding where i borrow
so if you say a negative
like level negative two which parts of
the expression does that referred to no
no i understand that but i
must do this right so map all right
map all applies to all levels so
so map ball doesn't uh uh you know
the this new value doesn't make sense
for map all right it's good for map
wait wait wait wait wait if i say this
oh i see that's already rodentifying
into the head so
it only affects negative levels wait a
second wait a second wait a second wait
a second
so map all
normally doesn't burrow into the head
right correct but with heads to true it
burrows
yep
right but map all applies to all levels
so it doesn't
matter how you're measuring the levels
right the issue is that if you're only
counting
down from the top then
you know you're counting down from the
top and the only question is do you
um uh enter the heads or not if you're
counting from the bottom
then you need to know how are you
measuring the depth
yes
so wait a second so in this case
i was at level -1 inside the head right
so how would this be different if heads
were full
guys how would this be different for
this map
at level minus one
minus one it might not be different
it might not be different because you're
only taking
basically atoms uh
you know including inside the heads so
you need sort of
minus two what the heck did this do
what did this even do right so it's
finding multiple parts
inside the head because you said head
goes to true but it's considering them
all to have depth two
as if you had heads goes to false
so it repeatedly applies f to that to
those parts that you find in the head
right i mean i do have some examples
in the previous section okay okay fine
but but
by the way this should be somewhere in
documentation this this
this is really confusing so what you're
saying is
that in heads
level minus two could actually apply to
multiple levels
like in other words my definition of a
level
is if i say position of that comma f
oh for goodness frigging's sake why
doesn't it get all of them
there's more to this this is more of a
mess than i thought
oh my gosh okay
so why exactly are those
because a of b and a of b
of x both have depth two with heads goes
to false
really oh because the guys say they have
really
why they have that depth too you don't
consider the depth of the head
okay they're both ahead with one level
of arguments
oh boy okay this is why this only
applies to negative level specs
right when you say positive when you
give a positive levels you're counting
down from the top
when you give a negative level spec
you're saying well you know
the depth of this expression is plus so
but then you need to define well how are
you defining depth
are you doing it with or without heads
okay but so heads is actually doing two
different things right
it's determining whether you go into the
head with with
a map and it's determining
whether you count heads for purposes of
negative levels correct
yes it's always a bad idea when these
things do two things
right so the other for example some
functions don't have the second
case right like map all
is only doing that first function
right so it's supposed to like head
levels arrow whatever
heads arrow whatever head levels arrow
whatever
or we could decorate the minus two
right um
right make more sense to me what's that
maybe the option is like head depths
goes to true false
i see that would make more sense
well it's head depth goes to all or head
depth
goes to one basically
right because in one case the head depth
is always one
is it not
the depth of a head with heads goes to
false is always one
true no no
right it depends on how many things it
has inside of it
but in the case you're saying just the
heads part oh i see what you're saying
uh it's
that that might be true i'm not willing
to promise that but
yes that does sound believable
okay so i mean
i guess the question is if we had this
as an independent option would it have
any effect when heads goes
to false and i don't think
it well i guess i think it would not
yeah i don't think it would because
only negative levels are considering the
depth
right
well i mean the settings will be
basically head depth to one
or head depths to automatic
or all
i mean in some formal sense but this is
getting
way too to over over
you know over thought it's kind of like
a head depth
function
although i'm not sure that this is right
i mean in other words if i
say yeah a head depth function
is saying it's always one so any minus
two or something
is already way above the head so to
speak
in over its head i'm not understanding
the one versus all
okay so i'm saying that that what what
is the case is that you always return if
you say
what is the effective depth of this head
the answer is always one
if you're not going inside it
or is it always zero
look what gets you the level minus one
without
okay in this case here
let's see this is level
boy this is confusing
okay that's level one in there okay so
now i say heads goes to true
okay confusingly
every piece here a of b
of x everything is treated as being of
depth one
and the and the f's are sprinkled on
that basis no it's that
a is depth one b is depth one
x is depth one b is depth one c is depth
one
it has nothing to do with a of b of x
because we're like oh
negative one all right okay so what's
the minimal example that does
is affected by this head depth thing
you had one the level negative two i
think that's in of
515 oh but
you can also look at me if you want to
look at express
yeah where is this
so uh i guess i think it's at the top of
this section there's an expression
oh i guess you can't necessarily well
you can't evaluate the pictures because
this is not a prototype build i presume
but um no it's not
but right so there i mean there i i
added the
right so i have
heads of heads and i have heads and a
couple of
you know compound heads in a couple of
different places
oh boy guys this is really
a head scratcher a detail
okay i think the example i put in chat
is a minimal example
okay
so what am i supposed to do with this
thing
so try map and i guess we'll
mask
and then do negative two for the level
okay and then do that with heads yes
right so the entire expression has depth
too because it has one level
of arguments but so does f of g of h
because it has one level of arguments
and so does f of g because there's one
level of arguments
okay so as sandra is pointing out on our
live stream and this is the point i was
making too
this is very weird right this is my
point about one of them is head depth
is a constant right because i could go
here
and you know do that it's still two
no new heads to true for depth
right but now is this head depth thing
relevant for this or not that's why i
was thinking the option would be head
depth goes to true or false because it's
specifying whether
the depth function whether it's heads
option is true or false
i see right yeah right because depth is
all
again depth is counting from the top
always it's just a matter of does it
actually enter the
the heads to look inside of them to see
if there's secretly
something deeper hiding inside of the
head or not
all right head depths
maybe arrow true or false
whether to count the depths of the head
in working out negative levels
you know what i find interesting about
this
a person who worked on smp invented
negative levels
in maybe 1980. okay
we are now in 2021 i don't believe this
issue has ever come up before
i mean unless you guys have been
harboring this issue for years
unless this is not no no no no no the
reason this came up is because he's
working on trees and when you
when you work on the tree when you look
at the trees you sort of see the issue
specifically fair enough pops out
but we've survived for 41 years without
nobody is suggesting that that we must
drop everything
to implement this right away but since
we're thinking about trees
we we should think about it two thirds
the lifespan of all programming language
development
that this has been not there um
all right i i suspect head depth are
true or false
or head depth sorry arrow true or false
okay makes sense all right this is
this is definitely in the in the in the
tentacles
department by the way when are we going
to get our beautiful tree visualizations
ian so we have a mock-up
or several mock-ups from billy that
we're looking at
um and jose and i are working on
implementing the actual
tree like okay can you throw me a mock
up in the chat i'd just like to see one
uh sure give me a second okay
right so this was an email you sent to
tlcc
and um
right and i'm not sure what the basic
problem is though so
here we are discussing it
okay the basic problem is
you know when you're dealing with formal
mathematical relations
this is the difference between equals
you know we are we are so 100 years ago
at this point this is the difference
between the metal logic and the logic
okay so what i mean by that is
there is a notion of equality which is
just a communal garden predicate
right like primality like this like an
arbitrary symbolic
predicate p and then there is the
i really mean equality and it's part of
my metal logic and it's part of the way
that i
actually do copy you know do
computations and inferences and things
if that makes sense okay
that issue came up a hundred years ago
it's biting us again now
so in other words for axiomatic theories
we actually
need two notions of equality i think it
comes up first with fields if i remember
correctly
that there's a notion of equality that
is a pure predicate
that's just like any old other predicate
which could also be an unevaluating
function like plus or something
and there's a notion of equality that
actually means these two expressions are
equal
and i think in some sense and this is
where i go off into
into weird stuff i'm still trying to
understand in higher category theory and
homotopic type theory and all this kind
of thing
i i think that in the end this univalent
axiom
thing univalence axiom thing is
something about equivalence of those two
things but nevertheless nominally
there is a notion of i just mean the
equality predicate
i actually trying to compute whether
these things are equal
okay so we have a third meaning of
equality which is
x single equals y
which means make it so you see what i'm
saying
right
right so there's assignment there's
assignments
there's there's test it and there's just
i want this hanging out there like a
list like other kinds of
you know things that i can operate on
from the outside i mean the issue is
is it equality that tests from the
inside that that on its own account
says i'm going to check whether these
things are equal or is it a quality that
is merely
hanging out to have things done to it
from the outside
okay now practical matter much more
elementary things
you know you're making a table of uh you
know addition facts two plus two equals
four
you'd like to have a
well i mean that one isn't going to work
for all kinds of reasons but but um
uh yeah i mean that's going to be a hold
form story at the best of times
well or or in or an inactivated story
that's true
i see so one of the questions will be
what about an inactivated equals
that's an interesting idea so i mean
what you're
saying is if i said
i have the impression that this would
not be enough because equal and inactive
equals are supposed to represent exactly
the same thing
and just that's not something that's
super easy to type in right really the
only way to type it in is to
do an active of equal of blonde oh
i know but i mean typing it in we could
solve a different way if we really think
though it was important to have
i mean this is really formal equals
right i think what is needed here is a
way of having some formal operators
without having to invade
these operators operators that we have
for the users
well right and you might say formal plus
is another thing we could have
exactly yeah so operators that we can
use for example in the enactmatic theory
without having to invade
another okay so i'm going to get more
funky
so for example we have right we have
like a dot equals
character so what's the argument
are you saying that something that
shouldn't be used jose and if so why
it's fine except for its appearance go
ahead
so my impression is that we want
something like we use formal
uh a it's something that the user
um that couldn't
it cannot have been given meaning but
for dot equal perhaps the user has
already
a meaning okay right so if we had
something that we it's ours
but doesn't have a formal mathematical
meaning
we could use it everywhere in x magnetic
theory
right so so you we could add a formal
well would this work uh uh
i think we have a formally i think yeah
i think
i think this would work i mean i would
have to discuss with john just make sure
i'm not missing something in terms of
parsing rules
but um we could create a formal equals
that type set similar
right with the dot underneath just like
other formal
how are we finding the dotty stuff
i certainly like it better than this the
two dots
yeah i know the question is are we going
down to zero
i mean you know in other words one thing
we could do is make these things gray
for example
yeah i i don't uh i'm not a fan of that
because
uh you know what if somebody right
you know what if somebody's putting it
on a gray background
or something whatever right i mean
forcing colors is
is but there might be a way to deal with
opacity that that has
i'm i'm i'm not super worried about that
issue
um
i would say it could be confused with
inactive
that's brownish
i you know i actually like you know i
like the dot but may you know that might
just be me
look the real problem with the dos is
not its appearance but typing it in
what happens if i do do we have the
alias
yeah it's a dot like that no we do not
got a it's dot a
oh i never use that alias i should use
that alias yeah we added that
uh in 120 i think i mean we didn't
always have it
right it was a dollar um
what's the which still works i'm sure
um i was gonna say is there any reason
not to have both
as aliases you mean a dot and dot a
yeah i don't know
i mean i i i don't think you know
proliferating the number of aliases just
because is
a good reason seems like it doesn't seem
like a great idea we might want to use
it for something else
but i mean potentially it could also be
improved through better auto completion
yeah i mean right now dot equal does
that but it doesn't need to do that i
mean it could be
it could turn it into formal equal
i always have a similar sorry i i was
going to mention that i always have a
similar problem when writing the
accented
spanish characters like a with an accent
i never remember whether it's
accent a or a accent i have to try both
that's interesting
because on a like a keyboard like at
least i know a typewriter you type the
accent first don't you
yes
[Music]
certainly in hebrew you don't in hebrew
you type the letter and then you type
the vowel well that's probably because
that was invented you know on
typewriters there are dead keys right if
you're going to type an accent
you want the accent and
inserted but the character not to move
and then you type the character exactly
and i suspect that's been grandfathered
to computers
i mean nowadays at least on mac you can
just hold down the a character
i know and it it shows you a um
which mainly that's for jose's benefit
[Laughter]
i i didn't know this i always use escape
a and then try the combinations a
randomly and one works
yeah i mean these it is remarkable some
of these little affordance things that
one never discovers
like i'm embarrassed when i hear about
things in notebooks that have been there
for 30 years and i didn't know about it
um well okay so the question here is
you know okay
should we bite the bullet and introduce
a collection of
formal you know we definitely by the
time we have formal bessel functions the
world has ended so to speak
we don't think there's i don't think
there's a much
danger of that i mean of course you can
inactivate
bezel j if you need to for some reason
uh but it'll just format as uh
you know as a brown issue i understand i
understand but i mean
formal plus formal times formal power
formally equal okay i guess the question
is what's formal power is that a carrot
because if if it's a superscript i don't
know how you make it formal
you have a little dot there i
was gonna say you turn the superscript
gray
oh boy no i mean i'm sure you could have
a little dot
in the sort of connector between the
base
and the exponent
[Music]
maybe
but i mean my concern is as soon as
we're going formal with these things
we're going to go on formal left
multiply formal write multiply and so on
where does that end i would say formal
plus
i mean plus times and equals would be
very useful for example
non-commutative multiply is used quite a
lot just to represent
products right
and so but what if you have two kinds of
multiplication
well at least having one more
would already i mean i plus that for
example i'm commutative multiply right
okay what about what about some negation
but when we look at that formal minus i
suppose
let me just wax ineloquently about this
issue
okay the basic problem is
i mean this is a hundred year old
problem
that we have managed to avoid for 40
years
that is
you know it's a what is mathematics type
problem because
you know we have a a symbol symbolic
system
yeah i mean okay basically the point is
this in our symbolic system
things like plus have a built-in meaning
but we can imagine a completely
devoid of meaning symbolic expression
system
i mean in a sense this is the transition
to the physics project
that the physics project is a giant
admittedly two-level rather than
infinite
level symbolic expression devoid of
meaning
where the things that would be pluses
and times
are the id of a particular atom of space
right it doesn't have a you know it
doesn't have a known
sort of centralized meaning whereas what
we
have been doing
yeah i mean
we're imagining that our expressions as
we usually build them
are kind of meaning first expressions
where am i going with this i mean
you know manipulating
expressions look the basic point is
with something like list
yeah here's my point my point is in some
sense
we want to deal with expressions that
just have structure
without any meaning without any content
but we need to know just like we do in a
graph
that that blob there is the same blob
as this blob here and that's exactly
what you know
in the whole hypograph formalism that's
exactly what we're doing we're just
saying
these blobs are meaningless but we're
going to tell you which blob is the same
as which other blob
making sense as opposed to what we're
doing
in our language in general which is we
are connecting
every blob here to a reservoir of
meaning
if that makes sense you know we're
saying this is plus
it's connected to the central meaning
reservoir of plus
whereas here all we're saying are which
blobs
have the same meaning
if that makes sense
did that make any sense
oh sorry i was mute i was muted uh yes
um
my my view of this comes from maximatic
theory so in the same way that in
maximatic theory we use format
a and format x to avoid a conflict with
the users a and x
we also use sql times and
sql plus etc and there's a danger that
the user might already be using them
so why not having some formal operators
for us
right but i mean the other point is in
principle
formal plus for look what this really is
is undefined operators
which are kind of um uh
um which are kind of
okay you could have two different pluses
right in principle
both annotated they're really anonymous
operators okay that's what we're talking
about it's anonymous operators
which are tagged as being oh this is
supposed to be a plussy thing
you see what i'm saying right
so i guess that's the thing which we
don't have we don't have the notion of
an anonymous operator
it's interesting actually it's an
interesting concept i mean
we do in a graph we have an anonymous we
have an anonymous
you know we have
you know binary relations in a graph
which are anonymous you see what i'm
saying and with with hypergraphs we
would have energy relations that are
anonymous
although even in the hypergraph
formalism for the physics project we
don't
have we just have a hypergraph we don't
have hypergraphs of hypergraphs so to
speak
but we could hmm
interesting i mean we have something
more like that in the combinator world
and so on but
okay let's imagine that we had a
completely anonymous
uh operator okay
which is merely
you know
we can get that from our symbol table
but it's very inelegant just like it
would be an elegant to label
you know we can have a graph
that sits there as a graph without us
having to say oh that node is labeled
you know 17 or something
for making sense like you don't care
what the names of the nodes are in the
graph
so similarly here what we're dealing
with and this relates all such trees i
suppose
is we're dealing with a tree where again
you know if i make a tree
right okay so here's here's a point if i
make a carry tree
okay there's a nice scary tree
actually let me make it um uh
let me make this say um ah
okay so there's my tree
okay that tree is very anonymous
it doesn't have any you know its nodes
don't mean anything
right now they don't necessarily labeled
or their labels are meaningless
but now if i want to actualize that tree
as something that represents polynomials
or something then i'm going to
connect those nodes to sort of the
reservoirs of meaning
that correspond to those things
ruffian on our livestream is commenting
about the relationship to type systems
i don't think i mean in other words
you could say i suppose
an operator is of such and such type i
don't think that really helps you very
much i mean i think it's the same issue
as just saying this node connects to
this other node
or
this is making any sense to people i
mean the the issue i claim
is we want anonymous operators anonymou
functions that that have
tags but not names
is my claim and then we want
transformation rules
oh boy what is this
um i mean you know clearly
in our symbolic language it's not
difficult to represent this i mean just
be nameless
of you know tagging
that would be the thing that would be
right is this making any sense
i mean that this would be the nameless
object
but it could have certain tagging in it
which could cause it to have various
kinds of print forms
i mean again you're not going to solve
by having a formal plus we don't solve
the problem of two pluses
right jose is very silent um i i was
thinking so
in my opinion we would help in those
cases for example in maximatic theory
which we need a plus and we currently
use c
or plus if we use formal plus
instead of of of try for example group
actions
in which we use a circle times
so my worry is what happens if a user is
using group theory and he
he has his own group theory using sql
plus already we might break something
i mean really what you should be using
there is a
a formal dot right which you know it was
clearly distinguishable from a colon
but right the the conventional
multiplication symbol no but look guys
guys
what you're really saying is you know
you call it a dart i call it the times
we call that whatever
none of those matter that's the whole
point that's the lesson
of a hundred years ago basically of the
development of sort of
formal axiomatic theories is it doesn't
really matter
you can you know what you call it is
merely a matter of human convenience
i mean that's in a sense that's what
makes our system possible
that we can have a symbolic system which
manipulates
generalized symbolic expressions without
pre-knowing their meaning
right so i mean in this case
you know you say dot i say times
somebody else says something else
all we need to do is to
agree that these are the axioms it
doesn't matter after that it doesn't
matter
all that matters is it you know it's a
scoped
thing so long as i state my propositions
in terms of that same
thing i don't care what it looks like
right the visual is completely
irrelevant it is
the important thing is is making sure
that that this
cannot have other meaning
that's my whole point that as soon as we
have something it's like
this node here better be connected to
this node but not
oops that node has a name which connects
it to this node that's no good
right but we know that's no good in a
graph
you know the collision of names in a
graph is
connections that shouldn't be there
right so they are numbered internally
and that solves the problem
so but it's it's uh yeah but it's a it's
a it's a
faux solution i mean it's like de bruyne
indices or something in in
lambda expressions it's like it's just a
you know it's a bookkeeping mechanism i
mean the look my attitude towards these
things has changed since
you know since the physics project
because the physics project is a story
where
you know it's like these are the
coordinates in space you know
we have these points in space and
yes we can attribute you know
coordinates to them but they do not
intrinsically carry them
and this is the same problem we're
having here that is
this thing okay is
you know we are presenting it as a
global axiom
with its tentacles hanging out so to
speak really what this should be
is more like an axiom function or
something
in which you know this isn't quite right
either
in which the operators are available
and this thing should be applied to
this isn't quite right this is not the
right way to think about it but it's
something more like that
where there's localization of the
you know of these formal operators
should be scoped
look the fact is we've got a problem
with formal operators
and the problem is not new you know it's
just like de bruyne indices and the
problem of of the um
of the naming of variables in
you know it is not new that that one
dates from well
it was certainly understood as a problem
by 1935.
um
the question is
there's got to be a really there's got
to be a really good general way to solve
this problem and i
claim that the way to solve it is
something like
there are expressions with nameless
operators
we could have a new character nameless
up
yes but i mean it but but you know and
it can have an infix form it can have
see what would happen if it may have
precedence of course that's another kind
of worms
oh my gosh that's the kind of worms
right yeah and and
certainly you know the front end
and the the language as it exists exists
now can't
really handle uh an operator of
indefinite
precedence well no you can't have it you
can't parse i mean
you know it's not our fault you can't
pass the thing of indefinite precedence
right right but while okay or or
let's say customizable right i mean well
we we know perfectly well and we've
already done it
that we can have precedence points
right if you have a continuous i mean
this is the question is
you know it's a it's a kind of a
dedicated problem
right if you have a continuous range of
precedences
then yes that's a different story okay
if all precedences is an order relation
we can't handle it as soon as we have
right as soon as we say the precedence
is 135
we can handle it if we have a discrete
number of precedence levels
right but right in
i don't even know i mean is it the case
that formerly
parsing just requires a um an order
relation on precedent on on operators
i don't think it can be enough no it
isn't because then you have
you can have you right you also need the
the
the the the grouping so is it
is it the infix prefix postfix and
you know which way does it associate
i think it gets even worse than that if
it doesn't associate at all i think
those cases where it's even worse
yeah we don't really handle that very
nicely
well right but i mean if when you have
two operators if you say
a op one b up to c
and actually boy that can get
complicated well
okay so i mean roughly
yeah and that gets even worse if you
have ternary operators
right which we only have you know we
only have
tilde right that's uh no that's not
right we have another ternary operator
don't we
well i mean we have things like tag set
and
yes that's right that's a ternary
operator also
um and i feel like there's something
involving
question marks somewhere right
okay with ternary operators and the
interspersing of order relations for
ternary operators good luck
yeah i mean i've often wanted
i mean for 30 years i've thought about
um basically
uh adjacency fixed operators in a graph
where basically instead of writing an
expression out
in pseudo-one-dimensional form you
basically are having
um you're representing things
you know like a category theory diagram
but not really like that because that's
more structured again
you're just representing things by
you're you're trying to turn a graph
into an expression and actually that's
an interesting question
ian for your you know um
tree expression right the question is
you know we there isn't a meaningful
notion of graph expression
there is a tree expression there isn't a
graph expression
i mean again the thing we're talking
about here is essentially a tree
expression
okay here's an amusing idea
trees have tagging information in
addition to payload right
in what sense well i mean they have
like options no actually that's not
right that's not right they have
it's almost like they are just like
experience understanding the tagging
that you're referring to to be kind of
like
what we're calling the payload like yes
hairy tree
and yeah there's one two three whatever
but you don't care
right instead what you care about are
the tags there
there's an idea here but i don't think
we quite have it i mean the the this
look this problem about formal
expressions
you know we need to solve it because
this is if we want to represent
so same issue where we mean representing
let me give you another example
okay so yeah this is actually a pretty
good example
and i think about it um let's see if i
can find it
uh let's see
okay when we are looking at
uh these formalized models of math
like like lean and metamath okay
they are just full of
concepts that are defined only by virtue
of you know they're only internally
defined if you understand what i'm
saying
is making any sense right
and but yet we want them to be
notationally
you know this is the mistake of lisp for
example that there is no notation and
when there's no notation it's absolutely
non-understandable by humans
so we want to get the best of both
worlds we both want something that's
meaningless
and that has indicative notation
if you see what i'm saying i mean when
we have plus
we think we know exactly what that means
um
but uh um
um the
um
you know what we want is kind of the
advisory notation of a plus
like the coloring of an edge and a graph
as green or something
but it isn't really very you know that's
not
really structurally important to it
the only thing we want here is that we
want to identity of things to be
structurally important that is
we say that operator is the same as that
other operator over here
honestly this is this is some uh
i need to go unfortunately in a second
but but um this is um
reminding me of something i'm trying to
figure out for sort of a
the bulk theory of meta mathematics this
is closely related
so this may be related like with our
symbolic representations of
like topology definitions yes
like in axiomatic theory you're just
dealing with the axioms and so you have
the operators that are present in the
axioms but in real math you're going to
have tons of definitional extensions
to your axiomatic theory and the way we
handled that was by having like a
symbolic
math wrapper that you put a string
inside and then
you know you just have that somewhere in
your big table
and then define formatting rules for it
yes that's directly analogous that's the
same idea
right i truly see that the general
problem here is hard
but in the same way that by having a 100
formal variables or so the latin agreed
characters
solved most of the problem for us i was
wondering whether having a few
of the most important formal operators
would solve most of the problem for us
well okay so one way to do that would be
to say yes i mean in a sense we've you
know one way to do that would be to say
there's a way of inputting and
outputting some of them
but internally they all work the same
they're all formal
of payload and that that is treated as
an atomic thing
but they're all you know in other words
the so that in principle you can
generate a new formal thing a new unique
formal thing if you needed it
and you know i mean it's it's up to
you could for example localize a formal
thing
somehow so that because that's going to
be another issue is that the collision
of names of these things
you know i think we're actually making
some progress on this formal um
uh
um yeah i mean this is interesting right
the
cover is commenting on the analogous to
particles and
and um and physics yeah this is
same issue i mean it's like it's it's a
proton
and they're all the same but yet they're
different type thing
um you know this is a good idea that
that there's some kind of formal
thing that can take anything inside it
that has certain i mean it's like our
calculus of annotations for graphs
when are two graphs the same
whether but the annotations are just
like for example
for we have made the decision right we
make the decision
the following decision which is not an
obvious decision but
we'll make it anyway okay so if i say xx
equals equals xx
and i turn that xx um
okay like this okay that will still be
true
it's not obvious that that should be
true right in other words that
annotation didn't matter to the meaning
and so similarly what i would suspect is
that we'll need some formal thing where
there's
two components to it there's
you know both what fundamentally
is it and what should it look like
so it might be i'm really a group theory
plus
that's defined as being a plus you know
that has this whole name group theory
plus
and it only and it never conflicts so if
we have ring theory plus it's not the
same plus
but yet its appearances i just look like
a plus sign
for example i look like a plus sign with
some standardized annotation
that means i i'm a plus sign an
appearance only type thing or maybe
maybe it's just a plus sign or maybe
there's some mouse over thing or
something like that that indicates that
it isn't
maybe it has a slight indication of not
being an ordinary plus
okay this is an interesting idea we
should continue at another time i i'm
actually really liking this idea because
it actually
as i say resonates with things i'm
trying to figure out about sort of the
bulk
treatment of metamathematics um and uh
it's always nice to be able to solve
these theoretical problems at the same
time one solves practical problems
but i it's really interesting in that
you've ended up independently inventing
basically the same idea
so can we can we get this either another
one of these meetings or an ild meeting
or something else to talk about possibly
even a custom meeting to talk about
formal
i mean we've tried this before talking
about formal variables but honestly
i think now i've realized it's sort of a
bigger problem and requires a more
general solution than we've talked about
previously
make sense so uh
to to be completely honest i got a
little loss on what exactly the proposal
is but
are you suggesting we need sort of a big
meeting
with john and other people or or do
we think i think this is more
theoretical mathematics stuff
i think that's a better i think that's
the more the direction i think
in terms of the front endery i think we
can solve that
okay i think this is more theoretical
math
discussion so so beyond jose
and michael will be a good person to
have
uh possibly jonathan okay
um i mean the axiomatic theory crew
because they're the ones and whoever ian
wants to bring in from the
uh you know mathematical structures
world and by the way you know
this is isn't this similar to what we
have in the geometry in the in the
you know synthetic geometry stuff
where we have again this notion of a
formal object that represents
you know the point a or something
not so much but i see where you're
thinking right
you know the thing is terrible i mean
i've been reading all the stuff that was
generated in the 1920s about
and they were grappling with the exact
same issues the difference is
they didn't have systems where they're
actually implementing these things so
there's a whole bunch of philosophical
stuff about
about the sort of uh symbolicizing of
things
but they didn't have it's like who cares
type thing and
and indeed it vanished without trace
over the past hundred years
um but now we actually have to solve it
so for another time um
okay thanks all i gotta run thanks to
folks on the live stream